[音楽]
体の声を聞くというテーマで今から
お話をしたいと思います
身体の声をつくっていうことを言うと
急にちょっと姿勢を正し始めたりとか組んでいたしを解いたりとかそういうことをし
始める方がたまにいるんです
お腹にもちょっと少しいたような感じがしましたが
その時撮った姿勢が
誰かに教えてもらった良い姿勢というものを再現したものなのか
もしくは自分の内発的な心地よさというものが現れた結果その形になったのか
このようなことが今日の話では大事になってきます
プロフィールでもご紹介いただいたように今僕は大学3年生をやりながら
溶岩の先生としての活動を少しずつしています
4はとは何か
一般的なイメージとしてはこのようなスタイリッシュな女性がいるものとか体の
柔らかい人がやるもの
もしくはちょっとマニアックなところになってくるとインドの道端で
家を捨て世俗を捨て修行しているような
業者たちこのような人たちを思い浮かべた方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
5年生をよがってのブックは
幸せに生きるための知恵だと思っています
主にインド人たちによって3000年とも4000年ともいわれる長い年月をかけて
育まれてきた
じゃあ背に生きるための知恵の集積です
僕は
女性でもないし業者でもないですがやはり毎日幸せに生きたいからヨガをしています
去年の夏
大学2年生の夏休みよりをして僕はこのヨガについて学ぶためにインドに行きました
約1か月滞在して1日8時間後間に100時間というなかなかハードなスケジュールの
中
洋画について学びます
そのプログラムの中で一つ印象的な出会いがあったのでその話をしたいと思います
こんな人です
僕が参加していたプログラムの中で瞑想の時間の先生だった人なんですが
先生といってもご覧の通り減額で近寄りがたい雰囲気というよりはむしろとても優しく
てフレンドリーな人でした
ある日食事のときにたまたま彼と席が隣になったので僕はちょっと質問してみました
北丸キューた質問はどんな食事をしたらいいのかということです
したら彼は次のように答えました
じゃスターす今日政府4ボディー wiiu テロ言う
ということでただ自分に危険そしたらお前の体が教えてくれるかという事ですよ
いつも優しくてなんかこんなに何かを教えてくれそうな顔をしているのにこの時ばかり
は何も教えてくれなかったんです
でも何も教えてくれないということ自体は実は最高の教えであるということが後々
わかってきます
この答えを聞いて向こう混乱すると同時にちょっと
恥ずかしい気持ちにもなりました
というのも北は本当に自分でやりたいことを見つけるためにわざわざインドまできた
つもりでした
だからインドに行くという決断自体も直感的に自分の声に従って決めたつもりだったん
です
自由な生き方がしたいとか自分がいい子で物事を決めたい
そんな風に思っていたはずの僕が
いざ口を開いたら何を食べたらいいかというすごく基本的で個人的で堅守的なレベルの
ことでさえ
体にいい食事という誰かが決めた基準を求めていたということに気づかされたんです
たぶん僕らは普段から
外的な基準に自分を沿わせていくという形の行動の仕方に慣れすぎていると思うんです
自分の体を誰かが決めた外の基準に吸わせる機械や道具のようなものとして扱う
だからこそ食べるとかって言っていった
動物的な原始的な行動でさえも
例えば目覚まし時計を何時にセットして起きるとか
何キロカロリーかに食事を抑えようとかそういう人的な操作を
西野的にしてると思うんですね
これはある意味でまあ仕方がないことでもあって人間が言語を持った社会的な存在で
ある以上どうしても基準というものを求めたがあります
このことは特に集団的な生活において秩序のある生活を営んだりとか
効率よく労働をしたりということにはとても大切で有効なことなんです
例えば小学校の教育思い浮かべてみるとそこでは国語よりも算数よりもなによりもまず
先に命令にで地者がうことができる
新たいからだってものを育成することに重点が置かれますだからこそ
椅子にきちんと座ってあるいは気を付けや体育座りをして話をちゃんと聞い
くっていうことがあれだけ重視されるわけです
このような行動として僕らの中に誰かが決めた
外にある基準に自分の体を従わせていくという行動の仕方が文字通り習慣化され進退化
されていると思うんです
でもこのようなあり方ってものすごく自己否定的だと思いませんか
自分のカードに対してもっとちゃんとしなさいとかきちんと良い姿勢を取りなさいって
言うのは
今のお前はダメだとか
ありのままの自分を垂らしないというふうに常に自分に言い聞かせているようなもの
です
普段からだと向き合う時間を作っているという方も
例えばダイエットとか筋力トレーニングみたいに
今より痩せたい今より強くなりたい
あるいはヨガにしても今より柔らかくなりたいというような未来志向型のアプローチで
体と向き合っている方が多いと思うんです
でもこれってやっぱり今の自分では足りないからもっと頑張れっていうニュアンスを
自己否定的なニュアンスを常に含んでしまっていますよ
僕はそうではないからだとの向き合い方もあるということを提案したいんです
どういうことかというと
今自分の身体がどんな状態であろうと思う
どんな声を走っていようとそれをそのまま向け受け入れてあげるっていうあり方です
ものすごく端的に言うと
生きているだけで素晴らしいっていうような視点に立ち返ってくることでもあります
僕のあるヨガの先生はこう言ってくれたんですが君がドアを開けてこの部屋に入って
くるそれだけで100万もの正しいことがそこで起きている
僕らの体が多少痩せていようが太って憂が身体が方過労が筋力は弱かろうがそんなこと
が問題にならないぐらい
一人一人は生命として存在しているという事実がとうとうになっていることを教えて
くれたんです
は僕らばに分配されている一つ一つの体っていうのは誰だ誰かが決めた基準とか命令を
実行するための動画なのではなくてその2は何かを感じてこれが好きとか
こうすればもっと楽しくなるって言った価値を主張する気
た存在なんです
だからこそ部から一人一人は
今何を感じているから何を欲しているかっていうすごくシンプルなところに
踊ってくる必要があると思うんですがこのシンプルさというのが意外と僕らには難しい
んですよね
だから
あのインドの先生がただ自分に着けって言ってた時に混乱してしまうんです
では体の声をつくっていうのはどのようにして可能になるか
ここで
僕がずっと学んできた武術とか前あるいはヨガっていった東洋の知恵が
役に立つと思うんです
これはの技法に共通しているものっていうのはある
非常にシンプルなタスクを自分に与えてやることによってその過程で自分の内的な声が
浮かび上がってくるということです
どういうことかというと
武術では
型稽古っていうのがありますよね方をこなすその過程で自分の体の癖っていうのが
浮かび上がってきます
あるいは僕がやっているヨガですと
ポーズの形ばかりが重視されがちですがその形をとるということ自体が大事なのでは
なくてその過程で起きている
今日の身体の調子呼吸の状態
それらを見ていくということの方が
重要だったりするんです
僕が大学1年生の時に立ち上げた大和塾という学生サークルがあるんですけれどそこは
このようなヨガとか武術の知恵を参考にしながら自分の身体と向き合う
ワークとか x ササイズを考案して
試していくという場なんですけれどもその中で僕の友人が
思いついたひとつ座ったままできる簡単な技法
今からちょっとご紹介したいと思います
こちら
20秒かけて笑顔になるまだやんないでくださいあの
みんなで一斉にスタートしているので
孫からスタートしてデッキだけ均一なペースでゆっくりと顔の表情筋を動かしてように
なっていくっていうやり方です
隣の人が見たらもう動いてるのか動いてないのかわかんないくらいゆっくり動いてみて
ください
もし笑顔になるのが嫌いとか辛いという方がいらっしゃったら無理してやる必要はない
んですが問題がなければやってみたいと思います
ではいきます20秒スタート
感じることです
ありがとうございますなんか素敵な笑顔はチラチラ見えて嬉しかったです
結構これって難しいと思うんですねゆっくり動いていくことってでもこの練習のいい
なって思うところは
仮にゆっくり動いていくことに成功しても
逆にちょっと失敗してピット早く動いてしまっても結果映画をになるということですね
だから仮にちょっと失敗してしまってもダメだなというふうに自分を責めるということ
はないと思うんです
そのま顔から笑顔になっていくその過程で
ちょっと顔が緊張してピック動いたりとか
あるいは何かそういえば最近心から笑えていなかったとかそういう自分の声に気付けた
方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
それが僕が繰り返し行っているあなたの身体の声ということなんですが
現代社会特に忙しい時代だからこそあえてこういう自分の
体と向き合うという時間を20秒でもいいので撮ってみるということを僕は提案したい
と思います
こういうワークの積み重ねが自分の体の声に対する感度を上げていくことでもあるん
です
ただやっぱりあのエクササイズっていうのはあくまでエクササイズなので
最後に実生活の中で自分の体の声を聞くというのはどういうことなのかっていうのを
紹介したいと思います
これまた僕の友人の例なんですが
彼はあ
慢性的な肩こりに悩まされていました
マヤもう大学生でも方交流時代なんですけど
彼の
肩の痛みというのは
彼にとって敵であって出来ればもうないことにしてしまいたような存在であったわけ
です
だから方が痛みが出るたびに本当にすごく
方に対して指定的に出てくるなっていうような感じですごく
否定的に振る舞っていたのです
でもある時彼が肩の痛みに少し向き合ってみるといつも痛みがあるわけではなくて特に
何か精神できない大きなストレスに刺された時に
生まれで方はアラームを流すかのように痛み出すっていうことに気付いたんです
これは身体というものが持っている本当に素晴らしい機能の一つ
体っていうのは僕らが精神的に崩壊してしまわないように
常にシグナルを痛みとか症状の形で知らせてくれているんですよね
彼が敵だと思っていた
痛みっていうのは実は一番3時間いる最高の先生でもあったということです
このことに気付いてから彼は
肩の痛みを
敵としてではなくてむしろ自分がどれくらいまあストレスを感じているかというのを
測るバロメーターみたいなものとして
後ろ感謝して受け止めるようになりました
そうなると今度は肩の痛みっていうのが
ストレスの自分が日頃から感じているストレス例えば
今一番の考えを言いたかったけどなんか抑圧してしまっていたとか
あとなこの部屋の空気が
自分の気に入らないとかそういった日常にあふれている小さなストレスに気づくことが
できるので今度は肩の痛みを未然に防ぐということさえできるようになるんです
痛みっていうのはある意味で一番わかりやすい身体からの声であり
だから今この会場の中でも痛みがある特に慢性的な痛みがあるという方もいらっしゃる
かもしれませんがその方はある意味チャンスだと思ってください
その痛みを切り口にして
彼が撮ったような身体とのコミュニケーションをとっていくそのきっかけになるかも
しれないからです
その痛みが出るときどんなときに痛みが出やすいか
痛みに付随してどんな新たい反応があるか
それはを見ていく事で
自分を知る手掛かりになるし
その感動を高めていくことで
今出ている症状とか痛みが出る前に未然に防ぐということさえできるようになってくる
かもしれません
では残念ながら今どこにも痛みがないという方
それでも体っていうの常に気づきであふれたばです
一条の中でも
例えばいつも自転車で移動してるけどなんだか今日歩きたい気分がするとか
いい人だと聞いて紹介してもらったけどなんかこの人の前に座ると呼吸が浅くなって
気分が悪いとかそういう普段見逃している些細な進退反応の中に4色ヒントが見つかる
はずです
そのような声が聞こえてきたときに
8時間の無駄だからいつも通り自転車で行こうとか
せっかくいいいい人を紹介してもらったんだから我慢しようみたいに最初に聞こえてい
たはずの身体からの声を押し殺さないでほしいんです
身体からの声を聞くっていうの時に社会的な
よいわるいっていった価値観と対立することであり勇気が要ることかもしれません
でも一般的な良い悪いと対立するということは今の社会にはない新しい価値を提案する
ということでもあるんです
もし僕らのみんなが
自分の身体をただ与えられた基準とか命令を実行するための道具としてだけ使っていた
としたらこの世界に何も新しい価値が生まれなくなってしまいます
しかも何より楽しくないと思うんですよ
価値が生まれてこないということも
一人一人が楽しくないということもこの世界から幸せが一つずつ減っていくことでも
ありますから
あなたが体の声を聞けるかという事は貴方だけの為だけじゃなくて
世界にとっても重要なわけです
身体の声を作っ
次に食べる食事の時でも
あるいは今まさにとっているその姿勢についてでも
できるところからぜひ始めてみてくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]